no no no no no no I quit I love this no
oh no oh oh oh it's just a blackhead
extraction oh right unless there's a
worm coming out of him oh man I live for
this it's like pus coming out oh no oh
my god you know like this is awkward
that's odd does this not grosser yet
are you just fascinated uh I'm pretty
grossed out but I can't look away
I can look away it is like weirdly
satisfying in like a weird way really
gross like Oh what part of his leg is it
Charlie's but no no we've got our cheese
right it's cheese it'll take a little
vagina it is it then go against
Instagram Java
I'm not even logic oh my so much but it
it must feel amazing oh it's big it's
big yeah get it alright alright come on
oh oh that's okay let's just play a game
real quick how much pus I think there's
gonna be like a decent amount all whole
bunch or just a little I'm gonna go with
a full one
what is it just frosting
ah-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha with attached to real
parts oh here's what I learned I only
like watching blackheads come out of
people's noses I feel queasy
I feel sad I'm not gonna go home and
like to relieve stress instead of like
lighting a candle and playing some music
there's kickball there's you know to me
I guess my question is like is it a
sadistic pleasure is it an interest in
the human body is it like what is it
that interests you about this it's
probably just it's like a weird
cathartic feeling like watching
something in six I I do wonder when I
see stuff like this like what would the
founding fathers think of this that was
my first thought as like Thomas
Jefferson what do you think about this
he probably would be Jewish